[Music]
why did you make me do that look at me
focus on my voice I'm not giving up on
you Jean she was my friend
you're my family James no matter what
look
you're special gene
and if you stop fighting that force
inside you
Foom Grayson
he will possess the very power of a pie
she'll kill us all tell me how we fix
this trough tell me what to do now don't
know what your turn
no they don't understand they fear and
what they fear we seek to destroy
it's your fault Charles I tried to
protect her
I'm scared
when I lose control bad things happen to
people like the girl dies she's still
Jean we can still help her
sometimes you want to believe people are
something that they are not
by the time you realize who they are
it's too late
she's coming
[Music]
you think you can fix me Jean you are
not broken
beautiful friend
the mind is a fragile thing takes only
the slightest tap to tip it in the wrong
direction
Charles what did you do I had to keep a
stable I protected her from the truth
there's another word for that I came
looking for answers you feel like you
don't belong here
you don't they can't begin to comprehend
what you are she's changing what we
didn't come here looking for answers you
came here looking for permission
she's in range hey miss water coming out
of us Jean Laska thought was she still a
Fed this is your fault Charles the world
is on the brink I'm sorry I didn't stop
it sooner you're always sorry Charles
and there's always a speech and nobody
cares they're still
don't do this
[Music]
the right to fear me I've seen evil
[Music]
I'm looking at it now
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]